et notre invités politiques ce matin ça
Sébastien Chenu bonjour bonjour
député du Nord vice-président du
rassemblement national on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par la presse du Nord la
Voix du Nord bonjour Julien les fillier
bonjour comment allez-vous monsieur
on va parler d'Emmanuel Macron Sébastien
Chenu Emmanuel Macron qui va faire
plusieurs
des années à venir il fera cet
après-midi en Alsace
il sera jeudi dans l'Hérault et hier il
était à Saint-Denis pour un déplacement
privé mais il a été chahuté accueilli
par plusieurs manifestants est-ce que
vous cautionner ce chalut à l'encontre
du président et moi j'ai une cautionne
pas les chahuts je cautionne ni les
chats je trouve que c'est pas
acceptable mais Emmanuel Macron doit se
rendre à l'évidence les Français ne
peuvent plus le voir en peinture ils
devaient venir d'ailleurs à Denain moi
je l'invite à venir dans ma
circonscription de Denain là où les
Français les premiers lui ont dit qu'ils
étaient hostiles à la réforme des
retraites je t'invite à venir voir ce
que les Français ont envie de lui dire
il va pas être accueilli avec des
bouquets de fleurs Emmanuel Macron la
politique qu'il mène elle est contre le
peuple français il impose au peuple
français des lois dans les Français
ultra majoritairement ne veulent pas
donc ensuite qu'il soit mal accueilli
qu'il soit chahuté bah oui oui
effectivement ça fait partie des choses
parce qu'en plus il a cherché à
bâillonner l'utilisation du 49-3 l'util
formation d'un certain nombre
d'argucides parlementaires et juridique
font que il a cherché à baillonner à
limiter les débats et les Français lui
en veulent terriblement il y a beaucoup
de ressentiments dans le pays Sébastien
Chenu le lendemain de l'adresse
d'Emmanuel Macron lundi vous avez réagi
en jugeant que sa principale faute je
vous cite avait été de dire qu'il allait
continuer comme si de rien n'était mais
qu'est-ce que vous ayez qu'ils disent
qu'il s'excuse qu'il retire sa réforme
sachant que s'il faisait ça il pouvait
tout aussi bien démissionner mais vous
venez de dire quelque chose d'abord s'il
avait présenté des excuses aux Français
pour la façon dont il a plongé le pays
dans un chaos et une impasse sociale
politique démocratique ça aurait pu être
accueilli avec beaucoup d'attention à
l'élection présidentielle pour vous
c'est pas un engagement mais Emmanuel
Macron a eu un discours totalement
incantatoire lundi soir avec des vœux
pieux avec des choses totalement
irréalistes j'ai rencontré des
professionnels de santé dernièrement il
nous dit qu'en 30 jours il va régler le
problème des urgences françaises
le problème des urgences françaises mais
enfin est-ce que il a bien en tête ce
que cela veut dire non je pense que le
Président de la République se moque des
Français je pense que c'est un exercice
de communication mais surtout dans
lequel il y a un vide sidéral qui m'est
apparu on a du fait qu'il est parlé de 3
minutes bière retraite c'est qu'il n'a
pas du tout par exemple parler de
l'inflation pas du tout parler du
pouvoir d'achat aujourd'hui
le principal vous attendiez à des
mesures concrètes c'est ça ben oui et
nous on en a fait des propositions sur
le pouvoir d'achat sur la vie chère on a
demandé qu'on passe comme dans d'autres
pays la TVA à 0% sur un panier de sans
produit de première nécessité de façon
cette cette mesure en Espagne on
regardait l'indice des portugaises aussi
en Espagne le prix de alimentaire moyen
a Bondy de 14% en janvier et de 16% en
mars ce qui montre que les la mesure a
été contrecarrée par une hausse brutale
des prix ça vous fait pas peur parce que
vous comptez appliquer non parce que moi
je pense que dans ces dispositions que
nous proposons mais c'est aussi la
baisse de la TVA sur les énergies à 5 et
demi pour cent mais ça c'est l'Union
européenne
la sortie du marché l'Union européenne
ne permet pas du tout ah non pas du tout
elle ne peut pas elle n'accepte pas la
baisse de TVA sur les produits polluants
non non là il y a plus il y a plusieurs
choses la sortie du marché européen de
l'électricité et tout à fait possible de
technique pour certains pays l'ont fait
l'Espagne d'ailleurs aussi je crois de
façon momentanée d'être momentané ou
durable je me rappelle de Bruno Le Maire
nous racontant qu'il allait étudier ça
qu'il allait regarder ça c'était il y a
six mois déjà devant le Parlement rien
il ne se passe rien en réalité ils l'ont
fait aucun geste le trimestre
des affichettes c'est tout mais ils
n'ont fait aucune non aucune mesure
durable et pérenne concernant le pouvoir
d'achat des Français d'ailleurs on le
voit bien la politique d'échec d'échec
qui entre nous et quand même
surprenantes payer donner des chèques
pour payer des taxes parce qu'il y a un
non sens économique absolu et bien ne
trouve pas n'est pas satisfaisant ne
trouve pas de satisfaction elle n'est
pas pérenne elle n'est pas durable ce
gouvernement ne fait rien concernant le
pouvoir d'achat des photos tout autant
il y a eu aussi un annonce d'impact de
la vie au travail c'est comme ça que
Emmanuel Macron l'appel il a accueilli
hier faute d'avoir l'Inter syndical à sa
table les organisations patronales et ce
qu'il faut est-ce que vous vous dites
quand même que il va falloir quand même
que tout ce monde se retrouve autour
d'une table pour renégocier et puis pour
reconstruire les conditions de travail
mais pour renégocier quoi à partir du
moment où le sujet numéro un c'est le
rejet de cette réforme des retraites et
qu'Emmanuel Macron refuse d'aborder ce
sujet des réformes de retraite c'est
très difficile de remettre les gens
autour d'une table avec des manœuvres
qui qui sont qui vise à changer à ouvrir
une nouvelle séquence parce qu'en fait
donc vous dites aux syndicat vous dites
au syndicats donc il faut pas y aller
non mais ce n'est pas ce que je dis je
dis qu'à un moment il y a des sujets à
prendre effectivement la souffrance au
travail etc sont des sujets importants
mais il y a comme un éléphant au milieu
de la pièce la réforme des retraites
dont personne ne veut Emmanuel Macron et
braquer sur ça tant qu'il y a cette
réforme des retraites évidemment ça va
bloquer les dialogues entre les
partenaires sociaux les dialogues dans
le monde politique le dialogue avec les
Français et je pense qu'Emmanuel Macron
sous-estime
l'impasse dans laquelle il a plongé
durablement le pays
parce que justement Emmanuel Macron
entre autre annonce a demandé à ce que
on relance on met des coalitions et
alliance nouvelle il a demandé à
Isabelle bande d'y travailler sur les
bases solides du Conseil national de la
refondation est-ce que c'est quelque
chose sur lequel vous pourriez vous
associer
je vois pas tellement en quoi ça veut
dire sur quel objectif on fait une
coalition quels sont les objectifs sur
lesquels
nous a démontré l'étendue de son
incompétence à créer une majorité sur la
réforme des retraites à la menti aux
Français elle avait dit j'ai une
majorité dans cette assemblée sur la
réforme des retraites évidemment elle ne
l'avait pas raison pour laquelle ils ont
déclenché le 49-3 et les bords c'est pas
la faute des divisions
elle est incapable de construire des
majorités elle a même indiqué à Marine
Le Pen lorsqu’elle l'a reçu il doit y
avoir un ralentissement de l'activité
parlementaire parce qu'on n'arrive pas à
créer des majorités
on aurait dû partir là avec la réforme
des retraites c'était un package fallait
faire un package born plus la réforme
des retraites voire même le président
ensemble c'est autre chose le président
de la République c'est quand même Marine
Le Pen a parlé de d'une démission de
président de la République à plusieurs
leviers je pense pour sortir d'une
impasse politique il a la dissolution il
a le retrait de la réforme il a le
référendum des missions il a plusieurs
leviers à lui de voir lequel est le plus
adapté le problème c'est qu'il n'en
utilise aucun prochaine étape
institutionnelle pour la réforme des
retraites c'est le 3 mai je vous le
conseille constitutionnel doit décider
s'il valide ou non le deuxième RIB vous
souhaitez qu'il soit validé oui mais moi
tout ce qui peut aller dans le sens
d'une consultation des Français je le
souhaite maintenant ce référendum
exactement c'est ce que j'allais vous
dire maintenant ce référendum c'est pas
pour ça qu'il va aboutir c'est une
formule très compliquée qui à la fin
revient devant les assemblées donc moi
je peux pas non plus qu'on donne de faux
espoirs aux Français
je pense qu'il y a toujours une bonne
raison pour qu'à la fin on aille pas
d'ailleurs cet outil c'est un outil de
régulation des colères qui avait inventé
Nicolas Sarkozy il a pas été utilisé et
je pense qu'il est très compliqué à
mettre en oeuvre nous on a déposé une
motion référendaire à l'Assemblée
nationale on a porté sur un plateau à
nos collègues de tous les bancs la
possibilité d'aller au référendum
ils l'ont la gauche en tête ils l'ont
refusé donc aujourd'hui entre entretenir
des espoirs au niveau des Français sur
la possibilité d'aller sur un référendum
qui nous paraît très hypothétique je
pense que c'est pas très simple non plus
il faut faire attention on va pas faire
croire aux Français tout ça va se régler
par un coup de baguette magique il y
avait des choses possibles la gauche les
a bloqué comme ils ont bloqué la
possibilité qu'on vote à l'Assemblée
nationale ils ont quand même une lourde
part de responsabilité la gauche dans ce
cette échec et cette bordélisation du
débat par des médecins
référendaire vous les avez rappelé mais
si il faut bon sur beaucoup de choses
mais si la nups c'est l'idiote par
exemple dépose une motion de censure
comme ils ont
l'intention est-ce que vous la voterez
oui parce que nous un nous ne sommes pas
des gens sectaires nous considérons que
nous devons utiliser tous les moyens
démocratiques qui permettent de mettre
en échec cette réforme des retraites et
que sans le rassemblement national toute
notion est impossible il est impossible
de la passer est impossible d'avoir
pensé que la prise de chance et pour ça
qu'elle a plus de chances que la que la
précédente qui a été rejetée pour neuf
voix oui probablement parce que il y a
peut-être quelques élus républicains qui
vont se sentir pousser des ailes qui
vont sentir avoir un peu de courage vous
me direz il faudra ouvrir le champagne
et à ce moment-là mais il y en aura
peut-être plus que que la dernière fois
si les républicains trouvent le chemin
du courage ce sera déjà ça de prix vous
me direz mais si c'est possible il faut
le faire évidemment qu'il faut le faire
cette réforme des retraites n'est pas
acceptable n'est pas juste elle est
rejetée dans le pays il faut sortir de
cet impact les Français savent qu'ils
peuvent compter sur nous pour ça
les socialistes vont déposer une
proposition de loi pour abroger la
retraite à 64 ans vous la voterez tout
ce qui peut faire échec à cette réforme
des retraites nous là voterons nous
l'avons démontré on a utilisé tout ce
qui était à notre pouvoir motion
référendaire motion de censure
amendement on a fait vivre le débat à
chaque fois qu'on a pu avancer pour
mettre en échec cette réforme des
retraites là où nous étions c'est à dire
à l'Assemblée nationale ou les nous ont
désigné nous l'avons fait donc nous
continuons à le faire parce qu'on n'est
pas des gens sectaires et aussi parce
que sans nous rien n'est possible là où
vous êtes un petit peu moins c'est dans
la rue mais aussi il faut bien dire que
l'Inter syndicale vous demande pas à
leurs côtés la CGT a annoncé de nouveaux
mouvements alors de demain chez
cheminots le 28 avril avant de la
manifestation du 1er mai est-ce que vous
soutenez cette mobilisation est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il faut trouver d'autres
moyens d'action parce que ça risque
d'épuiser les troupes bien sûr que
l'épuisement des troupes le coût
financier peut avoir le fait de faire
grève les heures qui peuvent effrayer
les gens sont des éléments qui peuvent
dévitaliser un moment ou un autre les
mobilisations sociales nous on n'est pas
un organe syndical c'est pas nous qui
donnons la bénédiction pour savoir si on
est d'accord ou pas avec les manifs mais
nous nous sommes favorables à continuer
le débat et donc une certaine forme de
mobilisation contre les retraites
mais vous savez moi je suis passé à la
manif la semaine dernière à Paris j'y
suis j'ai pas fait la manip j'y suis
passé je n'ai pas été mal accueilli
d'ailleurs j'y suis passé c'était à
Châtelet le 1er mai nous nous avons une
grande convention nationale comme le
chaque année sur le premier mai dans
lequel le travail sera le centre de nos
préoccupations de nous on se veut le
parti politique du travail la force
politique du travail du monde du travail
de la France qui travaille de la France
qui a travaillé de la France qui
voudrait travailler c'est nous qui
incarnons le mieux cette valeur là et
nous allons continuer à la défendre au
mois de juin
oui parce que parmi les modes d'action
on a vu fleurir sur les réseaux sociaux
un mot clé pas de retrait pas de Jo les
Jeux Olympiques qui deviennent un moyen
de pression est-ce que ça vous
interpelle moi je crois pas que feuille
tout mélanger les JO c'est autre chose
moi je serai plutôt fier que mon pays
accueille dignement les Jeux Olympiques
je pense qu'il y a des questions sur la
table des questions de sécurité dans
tous les sens du terme qui se pose je
pense que je suis pas sûr que le pays
soit totalement prêt maintenant perturbé
perturber les JO pour vous
me semble pas donner de notre pays une
image à l'international qui soit au
niveau de ce qu'on peut attendre
d'accord on va parler de la fraude
fiscale et sociale puisque c'est un des
objectifs du président un plan sera
présente au mois de mai Gabriel attaque
il y avait proposé à l'ensemble des
groupes parlementaires de participer à
l'élaboration de ce plan vous allez
participer oui mais bien sûr mais il
découvre la poudre ou quoi enfin je veux
dire ils sont comme des poules devant un
couteau en découvrant qu'il y a de la
France dans notre pays je rappelle
fraude à la TVA 15 milliards fraude
social 3 milliards fraude fiscales 80
milliards donc la fraude sociale elle
est importante et encore une fois nous
avons démontré par les propositions
qu'on a fait depuis longtemps notamment
dans des élections présidentielles
Marine Le Pen proposait plusieurs choses
la création d'un grand ministère de
lutte contre la fraude bon il n'a jamais
existé avec cette majorité qui est en
place depuis 6 ans mais surtout les
cartes vitales biométriques de façon à
ce que les données soient conservées sur
la carte Vitale ils n'ont jamais avancé
sur ça donc je le rappelle il y a la
fraude à la TVA la fraude sociale la
fraude fiscale c'est sur les trois types
de fraudes qu'il faut agir pas
uniquement sur la fraude sociale dont
parle Bruno Le Maire on va revenir à
Bruno Le Maire Gabriel attend il parle
des deux lui il dit il faut agir sur la
fraude sociale sur la fraude fiscale le
gouvernement souhaite supprimer le
versement des allocations sur des
comptes bancaires étrangers merci vaut
mieux surveiller le versement des
allocations pour lesquelles il y a une
condition de résidence en travaillant
avec les compagnies aériennes pour
tracer les allées et venus des personnes
concernez-vous soutenez ça oui d'accord
mais ça fait 6 ans qui sont là ça fait
des années qu'on en parle d'accord on
soutiendra tout ce qui peut permettre de
rendre leur argent aux Français on sait
très bien qu'il y a 15% des Soignies qui
réside pas en France on sait très bien
qu'il y a 2 millions et demi de cartes
de CMU qui sont à l'étranger mais enfin
on n'a pas découvert hier Bruno Le Maire
n'a pas découvert hier on sait ce qui se
passe il cherche de l'argent partout les
agences de notation vont rendre leur
verdict bientôt ils sont à l'os ils ont
fait n'importe quoi avec les finances
publiques ils sont totalement
incompétents ce que nous proposons hier
il nous accusait de dém moi je me
souviens quand on disait quand Marine Le
Pen portait ce message de lutte contre
la fraude au niveau qu'elle il doit être
porté en disant il y aura un grand
ministère de lutte contre la fraude
contre les fraude il nous accusait de
démagogie pour aujourd'hui piteusement
venir dire ah bah oui effectivement il y
a de la fraude on le dit depuis des
années on a fait des propositions parce
que on a réfléchi nous là-dessus depuis
des années bon je vous ai parlé de la
carte biométrique on a réfléchi depuis
des années avec des professionnels avec
des magistrats avec des services
financiers et aujourd'hui ils ont
l'impression de découvrir comment
retrouver un peu de moyens mais donc ces
gens ne sont pas sérieux en tout cas
vous nous dites il y a possibilité pour
pour vous de représenter vos
propositions et de les travailler avec
le gouvernement
qu'ils viennent sur nos propositions que
le gouvernement viennent soutenir nos
propositions vous savez on sera capable
d'en faire des dizaines et des dizaines
je vous donne un exemple quand l'État
veut se mobiliser et quand les
politiques veulent se mobiliser on peut
réussir moi quand j'ai été élu député de
Denain il y avait les fraudes sociales
très visibles dans la ville lié à des
populations j'ai le moins qu'on puisse
dire harceler le sous-préfet qui a mis
en place un CODEF qui réunit les
structures des services sociaux des
services fiscaux etc et on a des mantes
les centaines de faux dossiers de
dossiers de fraude sociale les gens à
partir du moment où le robinet a été
fermé sont partis ces populations sont
parties donc il y avait bien matière ça
va durer depuis des années il a fallu
évidemment l'arrivée d'un député du
rassemblement national pour que ça bouge
un peu c'est pareil au niveau de l'État
il faut l'arrivée du rassemblement
national pour que tout ça bouge autre
aussi
le maire a évoqué le ras-le-bol des
Français contre les personnes qui
envoient leur aide au Maghreb et
ailleurs alors qu'il n'y a pas droit il
a raison de pointer ses dérives plus
particulièrement puisque on sait que ça
a fait beaucoup réagir à gauche et ce
qu'il faut pointer du doigt les
populations que il faut dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont moi je vous ai
expliqué
la fraude sociale c'est 3 milliards
d'euros la TVA c'est 15 qu'il y a la
franchise calle c'est 80 milliards donc
il faut dire la fraude sociale ce
qu'elle pèse là où elle va dans des pays
d'Afrique oui d'accord mais bien sûr que
ça va dans le bon sens mais ça fait des
années qu'on le dit alors si ces gens
sont d'accord avec nous mais qu'il nous
laisse gérer les affaires du pays parce
que je pense qu'on fera mieux que parce
que je pense que ce sont des incapables
parce que quand pendant des années on
tourne les yeux on tourne le regard et
qu'on ne veut pas voir ça en face et
qu'on fait semblant de le découvrir le
jour où il y a plus un rond dans les
caisses c'est qu'on est incapable et
irresponsable autre sujet sur lequel
vous pourriez trouver peut-être un
trouver un terrain d'entendre avec le
gouvernement c'est c'est sur
l'immigration Emmanuel Macron revitalisé
malgré tout le projet de loi
azilimigration qu'on croyait perdu il
dit vouloir renforcer le contrôle de
l'immigration illégale tout en intégrant
de mieux ceux qui rejoignent notre pays
vous l'appelez à accélérer sur cette
question avant l'été non je l'appelle à
avoir une politique qui limite les flux
migratoires dans notre pays ça suffit ne
peut pas accueillir la terre entière
enfin j'ai regardé les chips même 48%
des gens de gauche qui se définissent
comme étant de gauche je pense qu'il y a
trop d'immigration dans notre pays donc
l'impression mais les chiffres ne disent
pas ça on est par rapport aux autres à
la moyenne des pays européens alors
continuons
la terre entière allons-y on accueille
pas la terre entière ça on ne peut plus
on a on a plus d'argent dans les caisses
ils ont creusé les déficits ils ont mis
l'État dans la situation financière que
vous connaissez c'était les Mozarts de
la finance on voit ce qu'ils ont fait et
maintenant ils voient l'immigration
comme un projet pour le marché du
travail et bien nous nous la voyons
comme un problème nous pensons qu'avec
le nombre de chômeurs que nous avons si
on forme mieux les Français sur Les
rémunère mieux dans les pays dans les
dans les professions en tension et bien
on résout une partie de ces
problématiques économiques il y a plein
de gens avec le gouvernement sur cette
question à partir du moment où ils
veulent ouvrir de nouvelles voies liées
à l'immigration maintenant s'il y a
quelques petites dispositifs disons
qu'il faut mieux apprendre le français
euh que les recours sur les occf seront
moins nombreux mais bien sûr mais tout
ça c'est j'allais dire c'est à la marge
c'est c'est minuscule par rapport à
l'ampleur de ce qui nous attend
entendons encore ce que disait Gérald de
Darmanin il y a un an 100 % des occultés
seront réalisés on en est où je fermerai
tous les points de deal en France on en
est où aller demander à lire à Roubaix à
Denain à Marseille à Arles où il y a
encore eu des tirs ces derniers jours si
les points de Deal sont fermés oui il y
a un lien évidemment avec l'immigration
et en particulier l'élimination
irrégulière oui évidemment c'est
insécurité endémique cette immigration
non contrôlée non maîtrisée dans notre
pays est insupportable pour les Français
l'immigration zéro
il faut tendre vers l'immigration zéro
il y aura toujours des étudiants qui
viendront étudier il faut les accueillir
et savoir qu'ils repartiront ensuite
dans le dans leur pays bien entendu mais
effectivement il faut tendre vers la fin
de politique migratoire incontrôlée sur
la polémique autour de l'attribution du
fond Marianne créé par manel Schiappa
après l'assassinat de Samuel Paty pour
riposter à la propagande séparatisme
Claude rénale le président de la
commission des finances du Sénat donné
jusqu'à ce soir au gouvernement pour lui
fournir les documents sur l'attribution
de ses fonds vous avez déposé une
demande de Commission
on a déposé effectivement une résolution
pour une commission d'enquête avec le
député Thomas ménager député du Loiret
parce que nous considérons qu'il y a là
visiblement un loup madame Schiappa a
créé un fond suite à l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty les produits de ce fond ne
sera évidemment pas dirigé vers les
bénéficiaires qu'on attend ou les
bénéficiaires n'en auraient pas fait
l'usage attendu ceci me semble la
commission d'enquête je l'espère il
s'agit de faire la transparence mais ça
dit plusieurs choses ça dit d'abord la
désinvolture pour ne pas dire mieux avec
laquelle la macronie gère l'argent
public il se croit tout permis ils font
ce qu'ils veulent de l'argent public ils
l'utilisent formal et visiblement en
plus il pourrait commettre un certain
nombre de délits s'il s'avérait
qu'effectivement tout ça était délictuel
donc on veut la lumière sur cette
affaire on ne lâchera pas Madame Michel
pas au lieu de poser dans Playboy
premier de répondre aux questions parce
que pour l'instant on l'a pas beaucoup
entendu au lieu d'insulter sa collègue
ministre de l'égalité homme-femme de sac
à main comme on le voit dans le Canard
Enchaîné d'aujourd'hui elle ferait mieux
de se mettre à travailler et surtout de
donner des explications où est passé
l'argent donc vous n'avez pas acheté
Playboy visiblement si je l'ai acheté
alors oui parce que j'aime bien savoir
de quoi je parle bon bah très bien vous
aurez appris quelque chose j'imagine le
lundi et lundi on apprenait alors oui
c'est moins moins je vous ai amusant
pour vous
[Musique]
exactement lundi on apprenait par Le
Parisien que plusieurs centaines d'élus
de tout bord aurait été inscrits alors
insu rassemblement national votre partie
a dénoncé une usure passion d'identité
il devait déposer une plainte alors
est-ce que cette plante déjà elle a été
déposée et deuxièmement est-ce que vous
avez des précisions sur cette mauvaise
position il y a pas de piratage c'est
effectivement une opération frauduleuse
avec un IP une adresse IP qui a été
construite et qui fait que en prenant
les dates de naissance des
parlementaires et leur adresse à
l'Assemblée nationale par exemple et
bien ils ont reçu je l'ai reçu moi-même
un formulaire pré rempli d'adhésion
c'est pas il y a pas de comment dire de
piratage mais c'est un remplissage
automatique de bulletins d'adhésion
c'est pas
un délit épouvantable ensemble les gens
mais nous on a déposé une panne si on a
déposé une plainte évidemment parce que
c'est notre image qui est utilisée et
qu'on veut abîmer à travers ça un mot
pour finir sur les sénatoriales au mois
de septembre vous avez investi vous
venez d'investir l'un de vos proches
pour les près de candidats dans le Nord
à l'heure actuelle vous n'avez aucun
sénateur quels sont vos objectifs
et de Denain qui est élu communautaire
qui est à la fois un militant un
professionnel et un élu qui connaît bien
le monde des collectivités locales qui
je pense deviendra sénateur du Nord qui
a 35 ans et bien c'est d'entrer au Sénat
notre objectif c'est d'entrer au Sénat
au plus grand nombre je pense qu'il y a
objectivement 5 départements qui
pourraient nous amener potentiellement
un sénateur et on s'était dit que si 5 a
été potentielles aujourd'hui et 5
renouvellement suivant ça nous permettra
de faire un groupe mais le Nord le
Pas-de-Calais les Pyrénées-Orientales je
les ai pas tous en tête la Moselle je
crois qu'il y a un département
d'outre-mer dans ces départements on
sait qu'il y a beaucoup de grands
électeurs mais moi je le dis aussi aux
grands électeurs qui sont pas
c'est-à-dire au maire aux élus
municipaux qui sont pas différents des
Français ne votez pas pour des listes et
pour des candidats qui d'une façon d'une
autre iront sauvé la tête d'Emmanuel
Macron ça ne sert à rien de voter pour
des sénateurs LR udi
horizons que sais-je socialiste etc à la
fin il sauve la tête d'Emmanuel Macron
donc je leur dis faites confiance aux
candidats du rassemblement national ah
je serai au char dans le Nord et aux
autres dans les départements
merci Julien merci Oriane la Une de La
Voix du Nord oui sur la seconde main le
nouveau filon c'est à la Une de La Voix
du Nord bonne vacances Julien merci
beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité merci Sébastien
Chenu on passe au club